[MUSIC PLAYING]
KYLE EWING: I mean, who
doesn't love a good story?
They're fun to tell.
They're fun to hear.
I think if we learned anything
over the last couple hours,
we learned that storytelling's
really empowering.
It connects us to other people.
It helps us relate to one
another on a level that you
might not see at first glance.
At a company like Google,
a data-driven company,
storytelling really helps us
bring some meaning to numbers.
It helps us actually add some
texture, some color to the work
that we do, and really give
meaning to all of those numbers
that we make sure we have
at the end of a program
or at the end of an event.
As a director in
people operations,
I lead a 300-person global team.
We've spent the
better part of a year
now really encouraging folks to
use the power of storytelling
to connect not only to
the work that they're
doing as individuals
or as an organization,
but to connect to each other,
and to really help others
see the impact of their
work through these stories.
If you take a step
back and you think
about the impact you're
having on somebody's life,
you take the time to
compile that story,
and then you actually
share that story,
it's going to help bring others
into the work that you're doing
and ultimately, make for
a much larger impact.
But I'm want to go a
little bit of a step
further because
for me personally,
I've found, through this
journey of storytelling,
that it's actually opened
a lot of doors for me.
And I'll explain a
little more about that.
I think last year was a tough
one for a lot of people.
And I know on my
team, there were
folks that were really
grappling with the impact
of some senseless tragedies
happening in the world.
And some folks on my team
started sharing their stories
with me, and just
started sharing with me
what it felt like to be black,
to be gay, to be scared,
to be angry, to be sad.
And it got me really
thinking a lot
about inclusion, what it
meant to be an ally, what
it meant to be a leader.
As the leader in
any organization,
you have one job, people.
Your people.
To make them the most
successful they can be.
To make them feel heard.
To make them feel seen.
To make them feel included.
So I took a few days and I
attended the Black Googler
Network trip in Washington DC.
I was one of two white
Googlers on the trip.
We spent three
days, 150 people--
community service, small
business consulting
on AdWords and other
Google products,
door-to-door voter registration,
some CS education work.
The trip was incredible.
The experience blew me away.
And it changed me.
It showed me the
power of community.
I was surprised to hear how much
my attendance and my support
meant to a lot of my
colleagues as well.
And when I think about
that specific moment
and kind of what even led to
the trip, it was kind of scary.
It was a little daunting.
And there were times it
was really uncomfortable.
But I'm so glad that I said
yes to that opportunity.
And it has opened quite
a few doors for me.
It connected me to
this amazing community
that I hadn't had a chance
to really be a part of
or get to know prior.
It led me to accept an
invitation I was so honored
to receive, which was to be the
executive sponsor of the San
Francisco chapter of the
Black Googler Network.
And it also led me recently
to accept a new role, where
I'm actually helping
Google really lead
the way in being the most
inclusive culture that there
is.
And to think that
none of that would
have happened if a
few brave souls hadn't
shared their stories with me.
So what I want you all to take
away from the last two hours
is that people want
to hear your story.
And I hope that now you've
got the tools to really
be able to think about your
story, develop your story,
share your story, say yes, and,
use, design, build on ideas,
and always be there--
take good care of yourself and
take good care of each other.
[MUSIC PLAYING]